welcome to this video Eric know every PA
you smile dominant so try the
accelerated dragon again this time I'm
going to know it got something entirely
different okay so that's not I have no
idea how this works right age 64 night
f5 name okay we moved it again so d6
looks finer in such a situation you
don't really like a 4m afford to be
played I one they're even quicker route
between 8-5 could be dangerous for him
you should one g7 looks very strong here
really quickly Catholic maybe just this
it goes to be three I have Bishop a sexy
that must be fine stop wired from
castling King side
now that that you shouldn't have allowed
that's going to be a problem okay yeah
like that you have to take whoa okay if
I check on e seven what's what is this
reply that must be a king moves Daniel
and then walk to the 8th yeah then you
create should work is cookie window is
it okay I can also check hear it I don't
think that leads to all that much well I
can do that in castle and that that's
it's pretty good actually so still loop
the a droopy one yeah am I losing the
Queen back maybe yeah come on I'll check
him here and just cancel short here i'm
still a piece up for two ponds f2 is
hanging and look the ages of threat for
2221 check made it should be too much
yes so look the eight I'm not meeting
him here 21 close close though okay okay
you should be roped in 353 those moves
they are certainly dangerous you cannot
take because the meydan be too I somehow
can threaten the made it will be tough
to defend any way I can that can
actually do the song and then creating
one major to move to cook the long grass
but up at the end I saw it Queen D 1
million to think is out of moves now
[Music]
the lake erie stood in Pennsylvania hmm
not quite sure maybe this also sit here
that course is called Arry play asian
yeah screen d1 you cannot answer anymore
yet this opening result looks looks bad
for white I know this is the line they
normally play a 4 go here i believe i'm
not sure i think here is six is the one
that makes more sense in connection with
this we should give for the nun probably
careful no but the line that the engine
gives us definitely a bit better for
white ok this is this kind of thing here
white has the better porn structures
little bit better firm yeah thank you
this is already questionable your you're
weakening your position along with white
and after after this it becomes becomes
becomes lost our sentences and that
doesn't work ok the air castles check it
was a bit stronger here and this is this
moment look I mean yeah can't hold the
winning but just appease up and let's
not not enough here here you're probably
going to win by made to aid yeah this
ambition be to a strongest yeah there
are some some attractive looking move
there like this for example attacking
hear em that's also not bad and because
the Queen doesn't have squares to go to
like here you go h5 and still are you
threatening the screen g1 stuff so now
there were many wins them yeah ok guys
thanks for watching